[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
guys trailer commentary for space jam
two
a new legacy i believe is this film um
this is just space jam colon a new
legacy no
no actual two in there no actual two
every sequel is a colon these days
so we're gonna talk about uh our our raw
unsensitive thoughts about the film show
you some deleted scenes uh respond to
questions and comments for viewers like
yourselves and then we are going to
tease you with next week's honest
trailer
this is gonna be a tough one for me to
talk about because i have completely
forgotten everything that happens in
this movie
nothing like a ton of stuff happens but
also
nothing happens i feel like i went into
a fugue state uh after
i think before the looney tunes showed
up and then i just snapped i was like
whoa what just happened
but um i guess that's my general uh
opening salvo uh what did you guys think
about space jam 2.
you were rehashing your fundamentals you
were just you know yeah
dribble dribble shoot yeah i saw this
with a group of drunk writers so i had a
grand old time and then had to watch it
again sober
and i don't uh i suggest doing the first
one and then not the second one
uh because the cracks really start to
show when you watch it that second sober
time
um but yeah it was fine like it was uh
it was a movie that was made of a bunch
of other movies
you know it was uh it reminds me of when
they run out of ideas for a show that's
been on for 10
seasons and they just do a clip show
yeah
it's like a cliff show yeah it was like
a sizzle reel for like what's coming
next year
at warner brothers yeah yeah i found the
whole thing really like
i don't even know if confusing is right
or like confounding where i was just
like
i kept i kept feeling like i was trying
to like get my footing under me like
what is the pit like what
in a in a sentence what is the new space
jam because it kind of feels like a
whole bunch of stuff and i couldn't
really
figure out what it was trying to be
that's sort of the first half and then
in the second half it settles into like
looney tunes basketball game like kind
of what you expect space jam to be
but at that point i was confounded just
because i was trying to figure out who
everybody in the background is
and most of them are not anybody they
make you this this promise that
this is a stadium full of warner
brothers characters
most of the time that means like batman
villain
batman villain none from the ken russell
film the devils
and then just like random steampunk
pirate looking people like most of them
are not even real characters and i found
that very confusing
no they're very like instead of taking
them out from the films and digitizing
them they were like hollywood boulevard
dress-up
versions yeah which one of them has a
knife who knows
right it very much feels like all of
them are going to hit lebron up for 10
bucks for
the photos that they were taking during
the movie
yeah yeah so i don't know we'll watch
the trailer and get into it i do
remember
having the thought um that al qaeda
should use this as
uh recruitment because the west has
become too decadent
like wow we've really this is this is
the the
terminus point of hollywood is like
where every movie is just cut up and
mashed up with every other movie and
sold
uh yeah i will say i i do think there is
something significant here this
and ready player one like the one shared
thread they both have that is weird
is that all of the references are
context-free
it's like these aren't the characters
like the white walkers aren't acting
like white walkers
like they're just there they look like
white walkers but they're cheering for a
basketball game with your real white
walker there's a hideous zombie they're
not going to cheer for a basketball game
yeah like first of all what is a
basketball game what is basketball
so i it's not even
cool like it's not even fun to see them
because they're just
visually represented but it's not really
these characters we love
in a scenario that's familiar it's like
a backdrop full of funko pops
yeah like a cold strong the cold storm
creamery of like
you just like dump a bunch of stuff on a
thing and like mix it all up and then
see
that's right i think this this is one of
those like
cold stove creamery abominations where
it's like 40 things in a cup
that's what this is that's this is this
movie i haven't been to a cold stone in
so long
remember how like buff everyone's
forearms were that worked there
they had to be from all of them yeah you
know all that
like popeye uh okay anyways let's let's
watch the uh on this trailer for
space jam coal and the new
[Music]
you legacy the first base jam because
you were like
eight now it's time for the next
generation to get their own looney tunes
nba crossover
but while the first one was merely
inspired by a commercial the all-new
sequel
just is a commercial
many people are actually clicking
what in the matrix it goes on like this
for like two hours let's go to it with
affiliate link or something
space just i mean it just to me is
asking the question like who is this for
like it's for children ostensibly but
none of these references are for kids
kids don't care about
any of the stuff that they're packing in
there right like even not even the
looney tunes
no trying to think of the last time that
a looney tunes thing was big and i can't
i said this on twitter that i thought of
the looney tunes as old man references
but apparently there have been they do
keep rehashing like cartoon network had
looney tunes shows and
so i do think kids know the looming but
right but in terms of like apparently
there was a show that people really
liked were kristen wiig
voiced uh lola bunny was like a
character on it like i didn't know about
any of this but that that is real
so i guess kids know looney tunes but
the rest of your point
absolutely it's just like game of
thrones and you know like they're just
mixing together
like it just seems yeah like the idea of
a movie for kids with like sprinkled in
references for the adults but that's now
like taken over
four quadrant where like the fifth
quadrant is just references yeah the
fifth quadrant is like the internal
brand marketing team at warner brothers
yeah it's all it's also weird that in a
movie for kids the lead character is
lebron
who is a guy that we know from other
media is capable of being really like
upbeat and fun and charismatic like he
has that side to his personality
but they chose to make his character the
really like he's the
overly serious angry dad who wants his
kid to like
do basketball drills instead of loving
video games
he was looking for a more serious part
you know he didn't want to get
pigeonholed
like you're doing he had training
be the wackiest version of yourself for
the space jam movie like
it's tuesday yeah it's incredible that
michael jordan
arguably gives the more charismatic
space gym lead performance like that's
wow i did not expect to be here saying
that oh well
all right keep going damn two a new
legacy
since 96 warner brothers has been
searching for an athlete big enough to
fill michael jordan's enormous genes
and after waiting for decades they
shrugged and settled for lebron james
the michael jordan of leaving for a
better team run out of teams to play for
he's a basketball icon who refuses to
shut up and dribble
in fact he'll say everything from what
what
what to what the what the what the
to a tiny
[Music]
in a performance that uses the latest in
practical and digital effects
to fix his airline i did i don't lean up
i mean danielle you're the chief
hairline inspector
correct it's a true story yes yes yes
yeah you definitely spotted that and
yeah he's
lebron struggled with his hair and i
respect that because you know we're all
getting up there it's all starting to go
but like this is
it was so dramatic it was like uh he
just showed up
on set with like a perfectly sharp like
bowl cut hairline look if you wanna
there's a product that will help you dye
your hairline if you need to just fill
in some holes so
uh you can go we're not sponsored so i'm
not giving them the spawn con
but you can go that little bulb that
he's spraying in there is like the
hairline fixer bulb
yeah also i thought it was funny that
they referenced barbershop because like
isn't barbershop the place to go when
you want to watch lebron james say the f
word i just thought it was really
interesting that they kept referencing
that
he's got that [ __ ] shop the shop yeah
the shop yeah the shop that's his that's
his uh that's his show on hbo where they
have conversations in a barbershop
yeah um and yeah i was thinking like
um uh michael jordan you're talking
about michael jordan's performance like
he's really so
nonchalant about everything in space
he gets sucked into a cartoon world he's
like bugs buddy and he's like
what's going on
yeah so i guess lebron's performance is
like in that vein where he's also
pretty unreactive to the situation yeah
he yeah like where is the guy from that
commercial where he played like eight
members of his own family like i thought
we were gonna get that lebron and we
really kind of don't
ah sure keep going weirdly mj would
never
watch is a guy who's known for being
electrifying on the court and a corny
goofball off it
is cast as a joyless grump who plays
boring basketball
everything in between these four lines
has worked and when his son dom gets
kidnapped by his nemesis
a cleverly named villain will win the
kid over by showing him all the love and
encouragement he's missing at home
forcing the dad to round up a bunch of
cartoonish misfits from a land where
they don't age and convince them to help
him fight back against the bad guy
until he learns to let loose have some
fun and believe he can fly
finger ring finger ring hey can we just
watch whoever is dead
this this this gives the lie to the oh
it's a kids movie like
layoff but because it's like kids movies
don't have to suck
like the exact same plot for
for hook is fantastic and like you know
i mean it's it's not it's unfair to hold
other kids movies like a pixar standard
but there's kids films every year that
are genuine and moving and tell a story
and are fun and wacky
and even can make room for some some
product placement
so it didn't have to be this way it
didn't
i will say i exclusively if i go to
mcdonald's i exclusively get happy meals
and i will say the lebron james happy
meal toy is mwah
they did a great job so they're at least
there's that is it cartoon lebron from
the movie oh yeah
and you press a little thing in his back
and it's got real basketball dribbling
action
oh there you go that's that's that's fun
here i've been wasting my life on
um mcdonald's breakfast when i i forgot
happy meal you can
order a happy meal as an adult yeah you
can just you can just do that no one
stops you
you might have a kid with you and i have
a kid
oh perfect yeah yeah you've got the
perfect cover like i have to pretend the
kid's in the car or something in the
trunk
it comes with apple spices who doesn't
like kids
that i wear on my back because she is a
demon
[Laughter]
so you know how that goes that's just a
reference to
lon's actual life all right keep going
that's not that's not an anime
don cheadle co-stars has a slightly
different kind of war machine
algae rhythm he's got a plan to steal
all lebron's social media followers
and like have fun with that dude he'll
do it by kidnapping some of basketball's
most available talent of the time of
filming
all to beat lebron and his son's blatant
nba jam rip-off
plus he wants to kill the looney tunes i
think it gets kind of murky
honestly once the horny nuns and the
iron giant showed up i just tuned out
and scanned the background for easter
eggs
oh hey look at that jabber jaw need
yeah how do you do fellow kids does
anyone want to take it
take a swing at lg rhythms plan
what it was anyone remember um he
wants to prove that he can make a movie
just by algorithms
um and so then he makes space jam a new
legend
he gets rejected no he gets rejected
from like movie making
so he's like instead i'm going to
make a basketball game and make everyone
watch me beat lebron james at
the basketball game i invented yeah
because lebron james made fun of his
great idea
so now he has to the al the algorithm
has to make fun of like has to humiliate
lebron james he's got a real
ego problem and then i feel like
there was a there was a pitch that was
space gen 2 is lebron's kid has invented
this basketball game
and somehow lebron and his kid get
sucked into the game
and the only way for them to get out is
to win
and they bring in the looney tunes to
help them i feel like because that makes
like that's like a
beginning middle and end and the bones
of that story are here
but it keeps getting like confused and
layered on and piled on with the
algorithm and the server
stuff and there's so much his how
important his followers were and
stealing social media followers and
stuff like that
right and then scanning and sucking real
people into the server verse and
who can get let out of the server verse
becomes very confusing
and yeah it's just like what is all of
this and i know we hit it on the head
but if you're dragging in a bunch of
people to watch a warner brothers
project
like 90 of them are just going to be
comments about restoring the snyder
verse
like i'm sorry like i know we hit it off
in a whole
section of the stadium it was just
really mad
guys who look like me like
bring back bat flick
oh yeah how did we miss this it should
have been in the video
they should have been on the trailer
yeah yeah all right keep going
do fellow kids well they got the looney
tunes they may have peaked during the
korean war
but that won't stop them from doing all
the latest memes of 2003
there's bugs bunny who turns in a
performance that can only be described
as
off-brand bugs bunny i'm a tune doc and
the return of lola bunny
a rabbit i'd like to flatter because of
her strong work ethic
yeah that's it but who cares about the
looney tunes
this movie sure doesn't what they really
want to showcase is warner's exciting
catalog of properties
that they've run into the ground from
the hit show that got ruined by its last
two seasons
the brandon of house stuff
to the hit films that got ruined by
their last two sequels
magnificent wine i love french wine to
the hippos
can't get enough can't get enough of
that guy bring him back yeah
he's coming that's what the kids want to
see he's confirmed back
he's gonna i believe correctly if i'm
wrong on this folks i think we have
confirmed marivinjian in matrix four
thank god i hope it's
entirely in context because i was
looking for like
what's like a good bad matrix sequel
clip and like
there's the finale where they're just
like and then there's you know there's
the cave cave
rave is fine i like the cave rave
i think architect to me number one is
architect that represents all the
definitely used that clip before
so number two with the bullet the very
vengeance
god wow i forgot that they were like
let's send them to a horny frenchman
yeah like 20 minutes 20 minute
digression about like
feeding monica bellucci sexy cake
digitally sexy cake or something
yeah all right anyways and yeah
i also the the architect scene in my
head has completely now merged with the
welfare
like i can't even picture the original
architect i just picture will
ferrell as the architect yeah good point
um it's just crazy
their three biggest things that they
have to showcase are
all in like various states of cardiac
arrest
like like game of thrones yeah um
you know uh matrix dead and uh
potter certainly struggling yeah yeah
it's uh
it's tough times so i guess they they
went easy on the dc stuff they couldn't
get like uh like a caval or an affleck
or someone to show up right or even a
momoa
that would be cool yeah that would have
been cool
i sort of expected that i figured
somebody from that world especially
because there's a whole
there's a little side bit with wonder
woman
and they brought in rosario dawson who's
certainly great and a recognizable voice
but you you definitely expect gal gadot
in there
right well then she does voice uh uh she
does the do the voice of wonder woman
and a bunch of their dc
animated so i guess they were like only
able to do the dc animated
but you would think that one of them
would have a day off where they could be
like
you know they were too busy filming the
imagine video i guess like they didn't
have time to come in
yeah so some huge missed opportunities
here uh as
the parent company of hbo to throw in
arliss um the rock from ballers
and uh uh ari gold from entourage
honestly if you're going to get bob wool
from our list to come back he could also
be alexander knox from batman 89. you've
got you've got multiple options there
boom yeah uh i still say yeah they've
bollywood
in the where was paulie they should have
brought in the watchman characters just
all blue dog
all blue dogs yeah enormous dogs in the
background
and restore the artless verse yes okay
keep going guys that's being ruined by
jk rowling's last two brain cells
honestly this one we should have focused
on wiley coyote if anyone he put up 524
points in the final game
mvp mvp yeah so enjoy the film
i mean i know it doesn't matter because
you know it's a cartoon
um but it hurt the finale to be like
this isn't basketball none of the rules
are different the points don't matter
like i know that the first one it was
like oh
they just scored 100 point shot but at
least you knew it was like basketball
so you could kind of follow it here you
didn't quite know
why anyone was winning or why it was
worth more than anything else like
i know porky pig won a rap battle
against nobody
and got a bunch of points for that it's
calvin ball
representative calvin ball yeah yeah i
mean well it's
like everything else in the movie they
introduced the concept of this
basketball game is going to be
significant in terms of the plot and
then they
basically just abandon it and it just
becomes total chaos that it felt like
everything like
they're like hey we're going to
introduce sarah silverman and steven
yoon as these
executives and then they show up and
then they don't do anything funny and
then we just forget about them and move
on and it's like
every 10 minutes the movie like it's
reset it's really bizarre
yeah lebron doesn't even do much in the
game
um michael jordan had that big like
extendo arm thing at least
um where's his where's his extendo arm
he's got that one where he like hits the
bonus
it's got to symbolize like he gets into
the kid like his son's
gay so rather than just trying to make
the shot he like hits the bonus
jumper or whatever uh there there is
that moment but
the power yeah maybe yeah it's just not
it's not like about
anything like nothing really culminates
in like a moment it's just like ah
here's some stuff
look at that scooby doo's there
who's that guy i think is that betty
davis i don't know let's move on
here's some stuff all right keep going
why would there be two penguins
with a villain who embodies a creatively
bankrupt movie studio
staffed by incompetent executives a new
idea from the algorithm
i'm listening some of the greatest 2d
animated characters of all time
transformed into cgi freaks against
their will
do not do that and a hero who laments
how corporations force ips to cross over
for cash
they all left then does exactly that
but who cares it's just a dumb kids
movie as long as they have that come on
and slam song in there we'll call it
even
come on slam or no one will feel welcome
at your jab
us or shame or shame there must be
the only way this is like excusable is
if the quad city dj's estate
is very predictable of their legacy they
saw the movie and they're like we will
not be associated with this
literally i had to go to the wikipedia
page and look up quad city dj's
controversies to see
some reason why i know why r kelly's not
on this one but where are the questions
not all of those people wanted to come
and ride the train it was non-consensual
some of them were like leave me off this
train and the quad city djs were
relentless
that train was ran so yeah it's crazy
that
that that the the second thing everybody
knows about space jam
uh that song was not even reference it
was in the trailer which is weird so
maybe what
what's the graver insult not featuring
come on and slam and welcome to the jam
in space jam 2 or not featuring the
original mortal kombat theme
in our new mortal kombat reboot they
sort of didn't know they built up to
that yeah
yeah they had a bit like a taste of it
it was a remix it was a remake
yeah just a little just a little taste
of it though and it's like fine you can
do
uh you could do a little remix version
of the quad city djs you know
yeah throw kid cuddy other whatever you
have to do
that's a depressing slam in jail yeah i
was just saying i just watched the bill
and ted one was like wow they're really
hoping kid cuddy has a long lasting
career because
uh he is in this movie um anyways uh
yeah spoiler alert for that
uh yeah come on inexcusable someone
someone give us the the real story for
why there's no quad city djs because
i i can't fathom why it wouldn't be in
there uh all right
let's finish up three cleveland steamer
say doc again i dare you him
what's up the
chungus that's big jungus personal foul
nice try movie but i'm also horny for
solid basketball fundamentals
james sorry don't get crossed
come on bro this character wasn't even
in the script
don just showed up on molly and started
talking like this
there's a good point that uh there's so
many references that aren't even
to warner bros properties like it's
alive that's like a universal
monster thing um yeah that's
frankenstein yeah
you had a you had a whole list of them
oh i did yeah i made i made a long list
because
after a while i was like wait a minute
because there's one there's one that's
like back to the future
where the scoreboard looks like the
delorean and it's like that's
that's a universal reference guys uh and
then there's um
at one point little rel goes anything is
possible
which is kevin garnett that's not that's
not a water brother's reference
yeah um so yeah there's there's a ton of
them uh and then the
the stop hammer time like wow how how
was
how was there an emcee hammer extended
joke in this
at which again you pointed out was
capital records uh now universal music
groups not
yeah the universal music group not
warner brothers star
are they warning us but they're about to
buy universal like is this
just like one of them's got all that
good ip yeah planted their flag uh
game blouses that was from surple show
which is by a com yeah
star trek viacom anyway star trek stuff
right yeah it's
like they ran out of references for
their own stuff you mad bro we got you
mad bro
well that's probably cameron yeah that's
camera you mad
a little bit sadly i'll bet billy warner
brothers to that footage
but also fox not warner brothers yeah
yeah
current defense okay anyways i know
about you billy boyle
we can just make cameron references all
day we could just make cameron
yeah child murderers and a woman who
tortures and imprisons her disabled
sister
good thing that cut peppy let you out of
this movie whew that could have been
problematic it's not tv
it's an ad for hbo
did a video game write this movie it's
like basketball but
better but everybody on the team plays
lebron dom built a video game
oh nice you're on video game let's get a
look at that game of yours hey if i'm
gonna be in this game i need a
superpower or something i need one of
those special modes
your game is amazing son style points
power ups
see kids playing video games do pay off
yeah camera gamers rise up yeah
a lot of gaming um okay well this was
fun
uh i'd like to support i like to stress
that's not a joke that makes sense
in the context of the movie at one point
little rel just turns to the camera and
says like
video games they're fantastic all right
let's move on with space jam too like it
literally is unprompted
yeah there's this big controversy like a
lot of people were mad at this movie
because like
they misidentified a gameboy color
they're like it's a game
handsome game what color but it wasn't
it's clearly just the original gameboy
yeah but i have a charitable
interpretation of this
line because he's like the game boy
color like i just got it
and then i thought he was handing him
his old game boy because
he has the game boy color so that was my
that's why i didn't put it in because
my line but you then see the game
that dom is playing or that young lebron
is playing and it is in color
it turns into color but i think that's
just because like you know
he's on dmt his imagination yeah like it
like
yeah the power of his imagination
he's the one guy that fell in love with
bugs bunny via game boy
at least make it tasmania like you do
something there you know
how we how we all got into the looney
tunes through all of their awesome video
platformers but all those great classic
platformers
he immediately threw it in the trash so
don't worry
the gift uh all right um so where are we
in the
in this in this whole uh things uh
we got some we got some clips yeah thank
you for watching and subscribing and all
that rigmarole uh let's watch some
deleted scenes
bang a rank banger ring hey can we just
watch hook instead
not all kids movies have to suck ass you
know starring
legally broad ready player brawn
zendaya is bunny women be hopping
listen i love the dom who loves his
family
ron bronze kids a kid in king james
court
cheetos never prosper algae in the house
windows 21 clippy's revenge
al gore rhythm tammy feels good to be a
gangster
space jam a new low
server jam doesn't have the same ring to
it
i p freely
[Laughter]
damn it why didn't we do that this isn't
a game
i need you focusing more instead of
playing with these toys you heard of the
e3 game design camp right
yeah i'm going you can't go to that
basketball camp is next weekend
you kids in your video games why can't
you buckle down and apply yourself to
something way more realistic
like being in the nba yeah i mean it's
more realistic for lebron's son
um but uh yeah there's like
the one thing less attainable than being
a game developer is like
being in the national basketball
association
you do you you do you um all right you
guys been
chatting along with us uh putting
comments and questions in the chat here
is some of them uh stephanie estelle
writes how does it feel to be able to
make an honest trailer so quickly after
the release of the movie thanks to
streaming
it feels spectacular i don't know
it's it's the same process for us um and
i guess i like it a little more because
uh we have a chance to be the first to
notice some things and point out some
stuff
um so we can be uh but also maybe i'd
like a middle
ground because it'd be nice to have a
few more weeks to really chew on it but
um i don't know what do you guys think
yeah like that
this isn't like as tight of a turnaround
like some of them we've done where it's
like the thing has come out on like a
friday or a monday and we're like trying
to turn it around
super quickly um but i do like having
just a little bit of time but yeah also
it is nice to get in before all the
memes and stuff
yeah yeah i really like being part of
the like
initial conversation people are having
about the movie instead of coming back a
few months later being like hey remember
this thing
here's our thoughts about it but there
are advantages to doing it because you
get to go a little deeper when you're
looking back on it and be like
here's how because we're also when we go
back after like the physical media comes
out
we're kind of looking back on that whole
cultural moment like
yeah this movie came out you all said
this this was the backlash
here was the response and now we're
gonna like sum up that whole thing
and it's really different to come in and
be like this just came out
like we're just going to dump all of our
thoughts on you i feel like the space
jam
this one in particular would probably be
really different if we were making it in
november instead of now yeah
yeah maybe we'll do it again uh lose
valenzuela i don't ever want to watch
this again
if they do make a sequel which celebrity
athlete would you pair with the looney
tunes i heard they were eyeing the rock
i guess it'd be like a wrestling thing
what what's uh what looney tune athlete
see i would i would stick with wrestling
and go with john cena because he's
already kind of like he dresses like a
giant
child like he's already tailor made to
be put into something like
the jorts and the big shirts like come
on he dresses like a sixth grader
um specifically a sixth grader in cross
colors in like 1992.
but so i think that he would be like a
really good fit for these and they've
done
like uh not with looney tunes but
they've done like
the wwe meets scooby-doo and like all of
these other kind of crossovers like in
cartoon form so they're
actors though right i mean like the rock
and john cena are like real actors i
feel like the spirit it has to be an
athlete struggling their way through
acting the role
yeah that's just personally just to say
my two cents but yeah naomi osaka
make her just make her life even worse
yeah or simone biles
yeah yeah oh she's having a tough time
i think marshawn i think marshawn lynch
has the personality like
of current working professional athletes
he
i most want to see beast mode mix it up
with the loot i think
also tony hawk would be really fun in
like a
skate or guy skate jam kind of movie
where he would be with the looty dudes i
i would be very good for that you get a
lot of those references of people being
like you look like tony hawk his
twitter yeah oh yeah you'd have so much
fun with people thinking he's every
other
white male celebrity around his age
other than tony hawk yeah
yeah i mean i'd i'd be into keeping it
in the nba and doing
like uh tim duncan or like a more boring
nba like larry bird i feel like that's
what this was written for was like a guy
who has a reputation for being like
cold and efficient but not excited right
that's the character as written which is
odd because it doesn't really feel like
lebron yeah uh or um
peyton manning's always funny on snl
right but i just remember him when he's
throwing like bullet passes into those
kids chest
so yeah um all right
uh let's see um i won't put you on the
spot with that one
uh james bunn asked what trend in
trailers do you guys hate
you have a trailer trend oh i'm i'm i'm
done with the slowed down version of the
song that we already know
i'm like super unless it's like sort of
never call you out but
granted this is about trailers but
didn't you just on this very program
last week
i did you're moved to tears by the slow
version of smells like teen spirit you
did
okay but that's also that's seattle bias
we've got to take my seattle bias out of
it because if they put that just in the
trailer it would not have moved me to
tears i would have been like what are
you doing
um there's no fish here to catch this
isn't for me
um but yeah so i think that that's the
one it just it feels like we get at
least like
seven of those a year and so that's what
makes it kind of exhausting
yeah uh i don't like the little mini
trailer
at the top before you get to see the
where it's like big climactic moment
coming big club actually moving
right they couldn't like to move it now
and then the trailer starts like i'm
about to watch the trailer you don't
need to sell me on the trailer i just
clicked on just get
just just go right into it that is what
uh james who submitted the question also
added that that for me it is the preview
to the trailer that you are creating
stop it what are you doing
yeah yeah i mean mine's an only but a
goodie but giving away the plot of the
movie
um don't need to see it and or like
every set piece
and uh i know granted they've they've
shown that that
works on people um like don't hold
anything back it makes sense um
once they've bought the ticket it's too
late um but come on man like
i i like to think that i'd be more moved
by the mystery than i would by seeing
you know act one two and three of the
film play out yeah
yeah i'm also annoyed by the time when
all like how
all the captions the all the action's
always interrupted by captions that if
you really go back and think about what
the captions said they don't
mean anything where it's like push
through see the world
do the thing and it's like what nobody's
even paying attention to
what these words are just show me the
movie yeah good point
um all right fight the world like what
that's every movie no that is jetly's
the one where he has to fight
yeah they're universal fights other use
with a motorcycle disturbed
great uh so uh next week we're going a
little bit back in time not too far
though um
for uh let's see um
something that would uh maybe a little
bit
hammy but it'll go good well on a
sandwich uh that's a clue for next
week's
honest trailer thank you so much for
joining us we'll be back next time
we'll see you then bye-bye
[Music]
you